buon pomeriggio a tutti sono da sempre
una persona molto curiosa e questo
perché sono stato cresciuto dai miei
genitori con il costante bisogno di
chiedermi il perché delle cose proprio
come la protagonista di questo libro per
bambini
questa favola racconta di questa bimba
che chiede costantemente al padre il
perché delle cose chiede perché il cielo
sia azzurro perché il sole sia in alto e
luminoso perché l'area sia fresca e
pungente d'inverno e afosa d'estate e
tutte queste domande che racchiudono
quella semplicità che noi definiremmo
infantile di fatto nascondono tutta la
bellezza della necessità di scoprire
come funziona il mondo da parte dei
bambini
inoltre seppur poste da una bambina
queste domande non trovano facilmente
una risposta
tant'è che il padre esasperato dalle
continue richieste della piccola non
sapendo più come risponderle a un certo
punto esclama perché sì
ecco questa frase perché sì io l'ho
odiata fin da quando ero bambino perché
di fatto non mi soddisfano la percepivo
come un limite alla memoria di scoprire
la mia voglia di capire come funzionasse
il mondo
poi crescendo ho imparato che cosa
significasse veramente quel perché si
cercava di nascondere ciò che gli adulti
non riuscivano a spiegare era una forma
di difesa pensateci pensate a qualcosa
in cui ritenete esperti
ebbene se voi non sapete spiegare quella
determinata cosa in modo semplice
lineare come se loro veste spiegare un
bambino voi non conoscete veramente
quell'argomento e questa è una cosa che
ho imparato col tempo quando a scuola e
poi in università pensavo di aver capito
qualcosa ma poi quando spiegarlo in
poche parole non ci riuscivo
facendo anche figuracce e quindi ho
capito che quel perché si era un modo da
parte dei miei genitori ma da chiunque
altro per farmi smettere di essere
curioso ma io non ci riuscivo io volevo
capire come funzionassero le cose e
quindi ho iniziato anch'io utilizzare
quella grandissima scatola virtuale nota
più comunemente come internet e
utilizzava questa nuova
tecnologia rendendomi conto non solo che
la grandezza del mondo della quantità di
informazioni che potevo trovare ma anche
della complessità nel recepirle
poi internet e la tecnologia prendono il
sopravvento rivoluzionano la vita di
tutti lo fanno in tantissimi modi
differenti ma ciò che quella che gli
esperti chiamano la quarta rivoluzione
industriale ha fatto veramente è stato
stravolgere i sistemi comunicativi e
informativi delle persone
ad un tratto ci siamo ritrovati con una
quantità abissale di informazioni che
così come in passato oggi non riusciamo
a gestire
tant'è che nel mercato del lavoro di
oggi si ricercano proprio professionisti
che siano in grado di elaborare i dati
semplificarli per poi utilizzarli a
vantaggio dell'impresa si è capito
l'importanza e le potenzialità del
flusso informativo ma allo stesso tempo
sono aumentate le difficoltà perché è
molto più complesso capirci qualcosa
un grande problema del nostro tempo
infatti è proprio l'incapacità di
comprendere se quelle informazioni siano
utilizzabili o meno utili non utili vere
o false riceviamo ormai così tanti input
che non sappiamo più come gestirli le
informazioni ci travolgono come un fiume
in piena e l'errore madornale a non
commettere mai proprio quello di
lasciarsi trasportare da esse smettere
di sviluppare senso critico
da qui nasce la cultura del dubbio ossia
discernere informazioni non fermarsi
all'apparenza prende le cose e
analizzare nel complesso capire tutto
ciò che si cela dietro di esse
ovvio questo non sta a significare
cadere nel piano scetticismo la cultura
dubbio mira altresì a risse e critici a
discernere le informazioni utilizzando
la propria vantaggio a verificare
costantemente la realtà dei fatti
proprio come ha fatto questo ma qui per
chi non lo conoscesse lui e michael
berry ed è famosa del mondo economico
anche perché è il protagonista del film
la grande scommessa
cosa ha fatto barry ci troviamo negli
stati uniti prima della crisi del 2008 è
un mondo dove le persone spendono
investono c'è grande prospettiva per il
futuro alle banche concedono mutui anche
a coloro che non se lo possono
permettere un periodo florido curioso il
caso in quegli anni
di una coppia di pensionati che viveva
con poco più di 900 dollari al mese a
cui era stato concesso uno strano mutuo
da 2 mila dollari al mese
e in questo contesto
nessuno si sarebbe mai immaginato quello
che sarebbe successo di lì a poco
a un certo punto michael barry non era
convinto di ciò che effettivamente era
il mondo si è posto un dubbio si è
chiesto ma ciò che tutti pensano sia
reale reale o non lo è
siamo davvero in presenza di un mercato
che cresce o in una bolla speculativa
lui non era tanto convinto della
correttezza operativa delle banche
e aveva ragione poi il tempo di della
ragione però cominciò a studiare le
caratteristiche dei contratti si rese
subito conto che c'era qualcosa che non
andava
c'era leganti fallaci operative da parte
degli intermediari di fatto alle banche
non interessava se a coloro a cui
concedevano i muti potevano
effettivamente pagarli
allora interessava massimizzare il
numero di mutui per poi infilare in dei
pacchetti che venivano offerti sul
mercato
in questo modo loro intascavano dei
soldi liquidi si liberavano di rischio
di mutui e lo ripartivano tra più
investitori era legale come cosa si era
l'edilizia moltissimo rispetto anche ai
tassi d'interesse di allora era
sostenibile a lungo termine
assolutamente no
michael berry si accorse proprio di
questo si rese conto che il castello di
carte che tutti avevano contribuito a
costruire era prossima a crollare allora
decise di fare una cosa un po insolita
decise di investire contro il mercato
andò dagli stessi intermediari
finanziari scommettendo sul crollo del
mercato americano
lì per lì finanziatori erano increduli
dicevano questo è pazzo ci sta regalando
i suoi soldi
erano come intrappolati incatenati nella
caverna di platone osservavano una
realtà che pensavano fosse reale ma che
non lo era quando si resero conto di ciò
che fosse veramente la realtà era ormai
troppo tardi la gente non comincia a
pagare i mutui perché non se lo può
permettere la crisi del 2008 si scatena
porta conseguenze globali ad oggi
riconosciuta ancora come una dei più
grandi crisi che la storia dell'umanità
abbia mai vissuto
uno dei pochi che si salva in quel
periodo è proprio questo qui è proprio
michael berry che con il colosso ha
fatto personalmente più di 100 milioni
di dollari
questo perché non si è fermata
all'apparenza si è posto un dubbio ha
saputo valutare tutte le informazioni in
gioco ha saputo essere critico
allora
intanto notate il boom che ha avuto nel
2008 il il mercato globale e stato
proprio devastante
allora l'esperienza di barry che cosa ci
insegna ci insegna che specialmente oggi
dobbiamo smetterla di pensare di sapere
tutto o addirittura abbandonarci a non
sapere nulla perché la prima via ci
porta alla superbia la seconda
all'accidia la verità come diceva
aristotele sta nel mezzo bisogna
chiedersi i motivi per i quali
tutto ciò ci succede nel mondo di oggi i
motivi detto le cose che accadono non
fermarsi all'apparenza anche in un mondo
dove sembra che sormonti su tutto il
resto e dove i social alimentano questo
fenomeno mostrandoci spesso una versione
che non sempre coincide con la realtà
allora per ricollegarmi al tema che è
messaggio in bottiglia
voglio lasciare anch'io un mio messaggio
a voi ovvero quello di non smettere mai
di dare retta a quella voce che i grandi
sbagliando definiscono infantile di chi
si chiede sempre perché grazie
[Applauso]